hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ich will heute Pico Park
zusammen mit mexify hallo hi ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht so richtig
worum es geht in diesem Spiel ähm wir
beiden müssen laufen und müssen uns
teleportieren und müssen uns ins Ziel
bewegen unsere Freundschaft wird hier
getestet okay
auf geht's
du weißt wie man springt ne
alles gut okay sehr gut okay weiter
geht's weiter
[Musik]
das ist das was ich meine wir wollten
wissen nein nein pass auf pass auf hör
mir zu okay ich hör zu drauf
okay
und jetzt wie kommst du
dann kann ich auch rüber oder lass mich
einfach
gar nichts okay dann warte ich hier
weitere Person die rüber möchte
das kann ein bisschen dauern aber ich
warte hier
wie geht's dir da drüben
okay dann warte ich hier
oh da bin ich wieder jetzt müssen wir da
oben hin den Schlüssel holen ne ja ich
glaube hier müssen zwei
sehr schön was machen wir jetzt mit dem
Schlüssel
kann ich gehen nee ich kann nicht gehen
doch gar nicht ich komme einfach nicht
mehr zurück
aber unser Schlüssel ist weg also der
Schlüssel war nur dazu da um die Tür
aufzumachen ne so und jetzt jetzt machen
wir komplett wir machen jetzt komplett
ohne fails okay nächstes Level komplett
ohne Fehler einfach nur durch Teamarbeit
nein nein nein nein also beides intim
und Team Schlüssel okay
guck mal wie stark wir sind ja krass ne
sehr gut jetzt hier hoch weiter rüber
das musst du wieder du alleine machen ne
ich gehe rauf
nee warte mal
warte
links und jetzt kannst du darüber
springen
wie schlau du bist Wahnsinn hey dieses
Spiel ist echt einfach sagen wir nach
den ersten ein Level also wir tun
ja das was nicht sehr gut tschüss
alles gut ah die sind für mich drauf
eins
[Musik]
ey guck mal du bist so schlau du musst
auf den letzten jetzt glaube ich
du bist witzig danke schön
ey dieses Spiel absolut Beschiss
[Musik]
ach so
jetzt müssen wir runter
holst du das Ding es ist doch
entspanntes Spiel ich glaube man könnte
so entspannt das Spielen
die ganze Zeit ja
sehr gut nein nein nein nein nein
was machen wir denn jetzt ich komme
nicht weg hier
doch okay
sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut okay weiter
drauf und ab ins Ziel es kann auch ein
bisschen schwerer sein ne wenn man mal
ehrlich ja also ja
Simulator das wird jetzt hier uns
aneinander rum lecken oder was
muss ich mitziehen
du machst gar nichts gerade ne
nee alles gut perfekt ja das ist jetzt
irgendwie ich kann ja auch gerade
irgendwie nichts machen hier unten ja
ich trinke kurz was ja perfekt macht das
ich bin so schlecht hey du musst warte
mal guten Sprung sehr gut und beide
okay stark hier hoch nee
[Musik]
runter
okay und jetzt Gehirn und zieh dich hoch
das ist so hohl dieses Spiel es ist so
süß aber ist auch so hohl
nein ich komme hoch
sterben ach es darf keiner von uns
sterben ich will immer so ein
Einzelgänger ja let's go ja ja ja
[Musik]
sehr gut sehr gut drin
sehr gut
wir brauchen wirklich ein bisschen
anspruchsvollere Level glaube ich
okay
oh nein wir sind wieder beide nicht
sterben
oh die müssen auf dem Kopf oh
ich muss auch bei dir drauf
okay sehr gut ich muss gar nichts machen
ich mache das schon oh nein
abends vielleicht muss jeder von uns
eins nehmen glaube ich okay
ja wie gesagt wir brauchen wirklich
anspruchsvollere Level hier für unsere
Köpfe wirklich warte ich nehme beide
okay
alles klar
wir sind so gut wirklich gestorben
sehr gut
schön könnte schwerer sein eigentlich es
könnte wirklich schwerer sein also jetzt
gerade aber wirklich wieder Quatsch hier
das Level ich glaube das Magnet nicht
loslassen okay danke dir ich nehme Dich
super okay ja rüber
aha
nice
ja klar
das ist eine Top Zeit die ist wirklich
wahnsinner
mach du mal weg
ich habe los geht's
los
[Musik]
saugen
hat sie nicht nach rechts gehen noch nee
da muss ich mir nicht
jetzt geht es Dir oder
ich hör auf und du siehst nach rechts
okay sehr gut das ist so einfach ey
wirklich wir brauchen diese Spiel nicht
mehr weiter spielen ich werde dann deine
Stelle jetzt auch beenden es ist so
einfach von uns wir sind zu schlau für
diese Spiel glaube ich oder ja können
wir auf das ist viel zu leicht hier
Kinder